hello rejects is Greg here with sir
Bailey epic voice guy just when you hear
it if I don't look at you just I'll be
in the room yeah like she calling on the
phone real quick just like you should
have seen the people at Universal
Studios when I went to the Transformers
right
Oh as Optimus Prime you do Optimus Prime
oh yeah I am I'm the voice of Optimus
Prime the minor rule is this thank you
for protecting our planet
these are nest soldiers so we're you
know what it's how I hear impressions
like oh yeah like cars three the trailer
just dropped Cars two vehicles in
disguise you should see another talking
vehicles cars too as though hail is like
the worst Pixar Pixar movie yeah
actually never caught it I I didn't
heritage I heard I saw the trailer it
looks [ __ ] wasn't even really cars - it
was mater yeah yeah like let's take our
sidekick and make them whole movie about
him because kids love it still made a
lot of money apparently that [ __ ] out
there cuz then you get the major in but
not nature's pistachio ice cream it
turns out to be wasabi and jumpin okay
can I just sit here and keep you off our
shoes for me and I'll do a reaction to
listening to you doing car soon I don't
really know what you want to listen to
but I'm like a channeling mr. peanut I
am speed you do the Wow right wow I'm an
animated car right I'm gonna into drive
since I worked on wedding crashers he
does this on and off camera - it's not
like cameras on let me get my voice just
his lifestyle or she wouldn't either
drive down cars three people the
greatest company
[Music]
their graphics have frickin fast lane
[Music]
whoa it's Disney but dark and brooding
the DC takeover figs are whoa like crap
[Music]
from this moment what the [ __ ]
they went dark how is that it's just
falling their eyes out everywhere why
was this so dark and serious Wow I have
expected a Pixar version of Ricky Bobby
to public I'm not sure what to do with
my hands right now
I like okay where's the punch line
how was it yeah yeah - something like
alright the reshow knows the cars right
now you're farting here say yeah it's
taking it back to the first one of the
races and all that okay cool
car flips and then there's like no punch
line it's just super [ __ ] seriously
dark why is it so done expected like
mater and Lightning to be like why did
you see that man my dad I can't believe
it surgery oh that was surreal how do
you go from cars morning to you like
didn't he look like a movie no ace isn't
like a serious drama he rebooted Days of
Thunder that's a great that's a great
battle you got the best one rather
suppose the best analogy because Tom
Cruise um Wow you can't even Wow
oh yeah Wow the only thing about the
trailer that really sucks is like let's
choose our normal aerial all caps fun
for the beginner
not even in each school movie title
headaches - yes thank you egregious they
spent all their money on the enemy shots
on your handout we don't have any money
for Day After Effects title change the
font here's some here here's some Adobe
Premiere Pro - that's for you
oh I saw the car 3 trailer leggings -
why are we confused even my best friend
it's gonna be one of those movies where
he starts off with him having a wreck
and he has to like rocky his way back to
the top like that oh my real man gotta
walk drive on three wheels I just I I
don't get what the marketing is that all
behind this like you have cars one which
is a family comedy than cars 2 which is
just apparently the most like a bad kid
it's just a direct-to-dvd that should
yeah direct-to-dvd they decided to throw
it in theaters and then this is like I
don't recall cars being like a super
heavy serious mixers if I mean they
they've always been emotional movies but
in have just so whole other directions I
was like seriously man that is man
that's dark if anything I'm hoping that
this next trailer follows up with
something just as dark it just stays
like just as Ariens the entire cast is
been replayed yeah
Oh Eddie Redmayne Stan they look like
first voiceover exactly his Tim hater oh
man I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on so are we ready man oh boy cuz the
first one was like you know it's a
typical family comedy right and then the
second one was I was some weird
adventure flick it was a spy movie for
me a spy was oh it was just dumb and I'm
like what that play for even younger
kids and the first the first one was
like an all-ages thing second one
definitely for kids this one I don't
know this looks like for serious dopes
and we support it has it has it been
that long were the kids that watch the
first maybe they're like they're all
grown they're so grown immediate doctors
are now they've all aged 10 whole years
has it even been out ten years is it I
don't I'm I gotta say
I'm I've seen a lot of killers this year
this by far is the most surprising one
that was that yeah no no sing-along so
what I was expecting somebody just to
even say something we did you say yeah
there's no doubt and with lightning
dying from this moment everything looks
I don't know maybe they're building up
to some big payoff in like manner also
and he's like that would be that would
be neat my name is lagdi McQueen Pixar's
car is directed by Michael Blake my
buddy Michael Buble Michael Blaine I
mean with music by Michael Buble well I
gotta see what some of these comets are
know we'll move on it's got seemed like
some people on the internet are actually
saying about this to see reason to be in
cars moving let alone a Pixar movie I
like it vixx are becoming a little bit
cars the darkest time this film is not
yet rated oh yeah somebody's basically
suggesting that Disney was drunk when
their hey Pixar he's like I mean yeah
what think it's like the fact that the
cars look even more realistic I love
these new ps4 games yeah maybe this
movie was made for the new VR when I die
and I've seen it through that maybe our
movies and like oh hey crab that would
be intense I feel like because the
graphics were even more realistic to
what actual cars look like I think made
it even a little more disturbing yes
very good
I honestly think just based on what
little they showed I honestly think that
they finally raised the level of their
the quality and like depth and detail of
the animation and they picked this film
to like launch like we're even better
than we were before yeah thought we were
good before this is gonna blow you away
cars three its the ones they chose all
the movies they could have ji would have
gone Incredibles probably yeah I was too
I think Incredibles 2 if there was a
dark just like if this is what if this
is gonna be the stable for the Pixar
movies to come oh man I am all about
everything that's coming out now yeah
cuz Pixar like except for bug's life
will never get a sequel I really liked
inside out a lot what I do I didn't love
it as much as I was watching a little
girl slowly go insane and yeah
all our memories disappear that's pretty
dark too they just said boo they did it
with a happy face this is for kids and
I'm crying
alright well you can't wait to see the
next trailer hope it's just as heavy
looks to like every job dad it was like
a Logan trailer just fall Oh Gloria is
gone it's like an apocalyptic role of
guards race bump yeah all right rejects
it renew the channel subscribe today get
accepted John Bailey you could catch his
channel and on social media
epic voice guy no epic voice guy he does
a lot of funny like random skits on
there
he does impressions it does other job
it's all kind of themed around funny
stuff a voice I also do some movie
review stuff and some trailer reactions
here in there too and he's also of
course the voice of honest trailers on
screen junkies so make sure to keep a
lookout for that and let's give a shout
out to JT JT dude what do you look like
about that hat on I've been wondering
that for a very is one of those like
Mario movie haircuts I Morgan over that
likes like a whole bunch of mohawk say
it like King Koopa hair that's why he
hides it I could see that he was an
extra in Fargo and they were looking for
change in my hair